jetzt beachtung verhandlungen die
spezialeinheiten der bundespolizei
kommen im morgengrauen mit flex und
ramme es ist eine riesige razzia gegen
skrupellose menschenhändler denn diese
banden zwingen junge frauen zur
prostitution in deutschland und die
sexsklavinnen müssen in schäbigen
hinterhof bordellen ihre schulden
abarbeiten
doch jetzt und das ist die gute
nachricht greift die polizei durch und
wir haben die elitepolizisten bei ihrem
zugriff exklusiv begleitet
damit willkommen zur achtung
veränderungen mein name ist maximilian
kiewel in unserem ersten fall heute
abend erzählen wir ihnen von
verzweifelten jungen frauen die in die
hände skrupelloser menschenhändler
geraten sind diese mädchen werden hier
in deutschland zur prostitution
gezwungen in schäbigen hinterhof
modellen ohne kontrolle ohne sicherheit
doch jetzt gab es eine riesige razzia
und gemeinsam mit meinen kollegen luca
witkowski und christian spreitz habe ich
die elite polizisten begleiten können
5 uhr 30 in der hauptstadt
polizeifahrzeuge rasen durch die
dunkelheit gleich schlagen sie zu riesen
razzia der bundespolizei gegen
skrupellose menschenhändler achtung
förderung ist mit dabei nach
monatelanger ermittler arbeit schlagen
die beamten an diesem morgen zu die
polizisten stürmen und durchsuchen mehr
als 30 gebäude in berlin unter anderem
auch gleich dort oben diese
sammelunterkunft
insgesamt 650 bundespolizisten sind im
einsatz sie schlagen zeitgleich zu kein
täter soll vorgewarnt werden niemand die
chance haben abzutauchen wir begleiten
eine spezielle beweis und
festnahmeeinheit die polizisten
vollstrecken einen haftbefehl der mann
den sie jagen ist wegen gewalt- und
drogendelikten polizeibekannt
plötzlich geht alles ganz schnell die
polizisten arbeiten sich vor dann der
zugriff die riesige razzia ist der
höhepunkt monatelanger ermittlungen
unsere ermittler prüfen im vorfeld jeden
einzelfall sehr intensiv und individuell
und da wird dann die entscheidung auch
getroffen wie das weitere vorgehen
gestaltet wird geht man eher sensibel
forum einen aussage eine aussage
bereitschaft nicht zu gefährden oder
geht man aufgrund der einschätzung der
person robust davor um die kollegen beim
bei der durchsuchungsmaßnahme nicht zu
gefährden hintergrund der ermittlungen
brutale menschenhändler nutzen das leid
junger vietnamesischer frauen aus und
locken sie nach deutschland hier
angekommen werden sie zur prostitution
in illegalen bordellen gezwungen nach
unseren erkenntnissen findet so was er
in hinterzimmern stadt also nicht
offiziell ich denke mal die vermittlung
läuft im mund propaganda die bedingungen
sind schlicht und einfach ohne kontrolle
jeglicher behörde als sexsklavinnen
müssen die frauen solange männer
bedienen bis ihre gigantischen schulden
für die illegalen schleusungen abgezahlt
sind pro schleusung kassieren die
menschenhändler bis zu 20.000 euro von
den jungen frauen wir hatten fälle wo
die prostituierten im schnitt 1000 euro
im monat verdient haben da wurde ein
großer teil dann von den organisatoren
einbehalten die konnten gerade so ihren
lebensunterhalt damit bestreiten
die ermittlungen der bundespolizei
laufen seit monaten
im frühjahr
2021 dieser zugriff beamte stürmen ein
hochhaus im berliner bezirk lichtenberg
mit einem trennschleifer öffnen sie die
tür sie nehmen die mutmaßliche chefin
der bande fest
gegen die partien in pumps wird wegen
des verdachts des gewerbsmäßigen
einschleusens von ausländern sowie der
zwangsprostitution ermittelt bei der
razzia stellen die polizisten
mobiltelefone sicher lesen daten und
kontakte aus und ermitteln so ein völlig
neues perfides geschäft einige der
zwangsprostituierten kamen schwanger
nach deutschland oder wurden in den
bordellen schwanger die schleuser
suchten nun im drogen und obdachlosen
milieu nach sogenannten schein väter
diese deutschen prägen entgelt und
erkennen im gegenzug dafür die
vaterschaft eines kindes so nur ein
geschleusten personen an was dazu führt
dass dieses kind die deutsche
staatsangehörigkeit erhält und die
mutter einen daueraufenthalt titel für
deutschland
zurück bei der razzia in berlin
lichtenberg armin g soll einer der
schein väter sein die bundespolizisten
stellen ihnen in seinem zimmer sichern
beweise kurz danach wird er abgeführt
insgesamt 18 deutsche männer und 23
vietnamesische frauen werden an diesem
tag festgenommen für die ermittler ist
es ein erfolgreicher schlag gegen die
schleuser band doch die bundespolizisten
wissen irgendwo in vietnam geraten in
diesen minuten schon die nächsten jungen
mädchen in die fänge der menschenhändler
und
über diesen fall wollen wir weiter
sprechen mit unserer achtung fahndung
expertin sandra schmidt früher
dienststellenleiterin bei der polizei
und heute professorin für die
einsatztaktik guten abend gute nacht und
es hat das beeindruckt 650 beamte rund
40 zielobjekte wie koordiniert man sowas
der einsätze dieser dimension sind
herkulesaufgaben und selbst erfahrene
polizeiführer sind durchaus
herausgefordert was hier ganz besonders
herausfordernd ist ist das erfordernis
der maximalen geheimhaltung bis zum
einsatz beginnen also sämtliche einsatz
vorbereitenden maßnahmen müssen absolut
konspirativ laufen um den einsatz erfolg
nicht zu gefährden und am einsatztag
muss dann alles stimmen dokumente müssen
da sein funkverbindung müssen stehen
einsatzkräfte müssen eingewiesen werden
oftmals wissen die selber bis zum tag
nicht worum es eigentlich geht also
welchen einzel gehen und dann gibt es
ein knopfdruck
zum zeitpunkt ickx und dann gehen die
türen zeitgleich in den verschiedenen
objekten auf und bestenfalls gibt es
dann die erfolgsmeldung an die
ermittlungs führen und einsatz für eine
stelle wenn wir einmal reinschauen in
dieses verfahren wir haben es gehört
vietnamesische schleuser die also junge
frauen nach deutschland bringen warum
ist das so schwer für die polizei diese
strukturen zu knacken und aufzubrechen
schleuserkriminalität ist organisierte
kriminalität die netzwerke die dahinter
stehen arbeiten sehr verdeckt sehr
konspirativ und die eigentlichen
drahtzieher an die kommt man nur schwer
an ethnisch geschlossenen gruppierungen
machen es uns schwer die sprachbarrieren
noch dazu als man kommt sehr schweren
die strukturen rein und niemand sagt
dort gegen einen anderen aus als es ganz
schwer die strukturen aufzuhellen was
weiß man über die arbeitsbedingungen von
diesen jungen frauen die dort
eingesperrt und zur prostitution
gezwungen werden es ist menschenunwürdig
und katastrophe anders kann man es nicht
bezeichnen junge frauen die sich ein
besseres leben in deutschland
verschaffen dafür ihr hab und gut geben
oder sich hoch verschulden wir haben
schlichtweg versklavt sie werden zu
identitäts losen sklavinnen in
deutschland sie arbeiten ohne papiere
sie arbeiten in niedriglohnsektoren sie
arbeiten werden unter umständen gewalt
gezwungen der prostitution nachzugehen
bekommt dafür keinen cent kann völlig
keine soziale absicherung keine
gesundheitsvorsorge
schlimm ja katastrophal wenn wir jetzt
neben gesehen haben es gab diese
zugriffe danach wenn all diese menschen
also mitgenommen wie koordiniert man da
die vernehmungen mit so vielen
tatverdächtigen beschuldigten ja auch
wie bei dem großeinsatz auf der straße
sozusagen müssen auch hier ganz viele
ermittler teams parallel arbeiten
vernehmung steens es geht darum den
tatbeweis sozusagen so stark zu
verdichten wie es nur geht die
tatverdächtigen zugeständnissen zu
bewegen indem sie täterwissen preisgeben
also wissen was no täter haben können
damit ist der beweis erbracht dass ist
waren es geht auch darum
inkriminierte vermögen abzuschöpfen und
die strukturen aufzuhellen das braucht
sehr sehr erfahrene vernehmer
vernehmungsbeamtin und beamten die sich
auch gegenseitig austauschen damit die
erkenntnisse aus der vernehmung in
andere vernehmung eingebracht werden
können mit vielen vielen dank dass sie
heute bei uns waren und danke für diese
expertise gerne dankeschön